well this morning we're getting a little
sneak peek at the new emerging food
trends that will eventually make their
way to local stores the fancy food show
is back in person this year and back in
las vegas for the first time in almost
50 years hector mejia is reporting live
from the las vegas convention center
this morning and hector tell us what's
extra fancy this year what are they
showcasing
so many things good morning to you sheri
so as we were searching for some food to
showcase we ran into this robot
apparently this is the future coffee
maker of the world this is one of 800
exhibitors out here revolutionizing the
food industry and for the first time
since the early 1970s the fancy food
show is making this stop here in las
vegas after spending decades and decades
in san francisco organizers say las
vegas is more affordable it's also a
fresh start their first convention in
two years after the pandemic hiatus
we're told during that pause you know
what really took off for uh
comfort foods pasta things to really
spice up daily menus and when it comes
to the trends people are becoming more
concerned about food waste and
sustainability
for example there's a cream cheese
spread made out of sunflower seeds
because it's a sustainable crop to grow
there's a vegan cheese made out of
carrots
rather than nuts because that's also a
sustainable crop but it takes less water
to grow
all right so today is the final day for
the trade show and if you're wondering
what happens to all the food the
exhibitors can't take home will it stay
here in the valley it'll be donated to
three square food bank that'll be tons
and tons of food and back out here live
you're not seeing the robot in action
because the trade show has not opened
yet for the day but this is artly the
barista bot and also a lot of the brands
you recognize today at the supermarket
actually had their start at this trade
show years ago when they were still
early companies and they actually have a
spot dedicated to those startups to sort
of give them more exposure and help them
grow reporting live hector mejia live
local now